bonjour à tous exceptionnellement
aujourd'hui nous allons commencer ce
journal par le sport il est vrai que
l'exploit réalisé hier sur la piste de
colloques de colombes par le coureur
français jean wadoux est lui même assez
exceptionnel
trois minutes 34 secondes nouveau record
d'europe
le record du monde approchez de neuf
dixièmes de seconde
michel jazy qui détenait l'ancien record
d'europe à plus de deux secondes
philippe gildas et bien d'un événement
où il faut d'abord dire que c'est
malheureusement la faute du vent si les
téléspectateurs n'ont pas pu voir hier
soir dans le journal de 19h45
wadoux battre le record de son ami jazy
il était 21 heures 25 effectivement
quand wadoux a décidé de s'aligner au
départ de la piste sur la piste octobre
nous sommes là à un peu moins de un peu
plus de 400 mètres de l'arrivée vous
voyez wadoux va bientôt se retrouver
seul en tête jusqu ici il a été tiré
littéralement selon le plan établi
successivement par viau puis par blondel
puis par tous à vaduz se tenant toujours
en quatrième position bien à l'abri et
là il va faire le dernier tour tout seul
un rythme extrêmement régulier jusque là
peut être un peu vite au 800 m puisque
couvert en une minute 55 alors que
l'actuel recordman du monde ryan n'était
passé en une minute 56 et c'est
peut-être à cause de ce passage un peu
rapide dans les deux premiers tours peut
être aussi à cause du vent que java d'où
va céder un peu dans les derniers 400
mètres surtout dans la ligne droite
sinon il faut le dire wadoux au raid été
recordman du monde
en effet un tour de l'arrivée il était
encore en avance d'une seconde sur le
temps du record de ryan je vous rappelle
maintenant le temps de vaduz il lui
reste seulement la ligne droite et sur
ces 15 100 m il va réaliser 3 34 c'est à
dire dans quelques mètres maintenant
deux secondes et trois dixièmes de moins
que michel geste le record de ryan
depuis 67 à los angeles 3 33 une c'est à
dire neuf dixièmes de plus et vaduz qui
est maintenant un grand coureur de 5000
aussi va pouvoir récupérer très
rapidement vous le voyez d'ailleurs là
il va retrouver très rapidement son
souffle et parlait déjà du record du
monde autour de ce record je fais 3 37 7
ans 66 ans les conditions sont mauvaises
déjà c'était pas je comptais un peu sur
le record d'europe et puis j'ai eu pas
mal de déboires et là je ne croyais plus
trop mais je savais que j'étais une
femme très très bonne en ce moment et je
voulais exploiter les dimanches soirs
nomi sauber au club même au point ce ce
cas c'est finalement c'est une école de
la rigueur une course parfaite une
course terrible parce que sur les trois
copains qui vraiment ont donné le
meilleur sous titrage un truc quoi
pendant toute la course et vous pouvez
pas savoir ce que l'effet que ça peut
faire lorsqu'on derrière que l'on sait
que les gars devant donne le maximum
on peut viser le top j'ai dit allez et
puis aussi autre chose
il n'y avait pas de public ce soir à
colombes mais il n'y avait que des amis
qui étaient tous sur la pelouse en
encourager et ça ça vaut tout public du
monde
comment alors jean wadoux c'est le futur
recordman du monde du 400 puisque vous
parliez de vous attaquer notre foi au
record du monde cette fois c'est juste
tellement étonné si près du record du
nom de relance ça dépasse toutes les
espérances c'est dommage de manquer de
si peu alors fracassé le record d'europe
est vraiment je suis très heureux
peut-être que je regretterai mais pour
le moment je suis très heureux alors est
ce que c'est votre dernier quinze 100 m
pour le dernier non sans jeu je fais 1
400 à la coupe d'europe le 1er 2e ou 1er
roupies tour puisque c'est le 15 5
premiers jours mais je ne pense pas que
ce soit l'occasion favorable parler dans
les coupes sur un homme il ya souvent
des courses techniques qui d'ailleurs ne
le place pas beaucoup alors vous êtes
meilleur sur sa ville ou sur 15 ans ça
vous aideront peut-être de nouveaux
horizons à 34 c à 2013 et 1,8 pour le
lancer de ce que je peux vous dire non
vous n'êtes pas fatigué du tout délai
votre arrivée vous avez parlé on n'a
rien contre du tour de france au soir
d'une étape de cols par exemple
ces libertés en civière mais je n'étais
pas fatiguée mais je fatigue
musculairement je n'ai pas encore bien
l'habitude du rythme du 40 au moins
c'est ce niveau là et c'est mon second
de 3,47 année j'ai peiné un peu dans les
trois centres animés après seulement un
peu ce matin j'ai vu l'équipe qui est
nôtre de 52,7 au passage de 12 cents à
edimbourg jamais eu mais il est fou
c'est impossible
et puis quand j'ai entendu 3,50 2,50 de
une pour mort ou 12 cents alors que vous
rêvez parce que vraiment j'étais frais
vous vous êtes dit que j'aimerais de
l'étude un peu fou aussi faim a pas du
tout j'étais bien j'étais bien là je me
suis dit ça ne va peut-être pas duré
longtemps
vous avez souffert des jeunes motivés
non sûre quand vous savez lorsqu'on
habitudes du 5000 le 15 sans est très
facile oui c'est vraiment un très bel
exploit mais tout est quelque chose qui
me tracasse un peu philippe gildas jean
adoue a tout de même été tirée par
plusieurs hier une sont des conditions
d'affaires est visé c'est parfaitement
annulé hier la plupart de recours baddou
l'a dit lui-même la plupart des records
s'établissent dans ces conditions alors
que dans les grandes compétitions il
s'agit d'abord de gagner beaucoup plus
d'établir un record
il ya il faut dire que l'ailière en
question n'ont pas abandonné ils ont
tous terminé hier l'un effectivement les
vingt ans qui habite près des îles qui a
pratiquement couru le 5000 en cinq
minutes c'est à dire une minute trente
de plus que 22 mai celui l'avait fait
les 400 premiers mètres à toute allure
mon assiette courant s'est amélioré un
record qui appartenait à la france
d'ailleurs et bien aux femmes elles en
ont perdu un autre nicole duclos et
colette besson ne sont plus records vous
mène de du monde du 400 m elle avait
réalisé 50 et une secondes 7/10 lors de
la finale des championnats d'europe
athènes au mois de septembre dernier
et bien hier à edimbourg à l'occasion
des jeux du commonwealth
une jeune jamaïcaine de 18 ans qui
s'appelle marie line neuville a fait
mieux puisqu'elle a descendu le record
du monde à 51 secondes juste gaza
oui c'est une petite fille elle a mûri
natale encore 18 ans mais c'est déjà une
forte femme d'ailleurs vous allez la
voir marilyn nos villes
elle porte dans cette cause et d'un but
a le numéro 1 485 d'ailleurs c'est très
facile
elle est là où un numéro 3 il ya plus
maman de balles réelles
que quatre athlètes elle va les
rattraper très rapidement un texte sale
qui finira deuxième c'est la ghanéenne
donc après 100 mètres de course il n'ya
déjà plus aucun doute
nabila en navette ou le décalage elle va
passer au 200 m en 23 secondes 8 on sait
déjà que c'est patent fabuleux la
question est de savoir à ce moment là si
elle va tenir
et puis dans le virage no ville ne
faiblit pas il reste toute la ligne
droite où les grisons sont déjà très
largement distancée la ghanéenne à
l'extérieur à peut-être réussi à tenir
mais là dans la ligne at elle va craquer
totalement
et puis la ville compte tenu de la même
foulée ça se passe de commentaire
de la loi que minime qui lui même
reconnaît spectateurs d'ailleurs tous
ont manqué les commentateurs nous disent
tous se mettent tous les commentateurs
disent qu'elle a passé avec succès
l'épreuve de sexe c'est exact
championnats d'europe l'an dernier est
là il est d'ailleurs un problème c'est
que l'on gagnait les têtes anglaises et
américaines et cette année les
américaines et la cour où c'est
d'ailleurs une question assez
douloureuse pour les britanniques parce
qu'il se pourrait bien qu'elle ne puisse
pas participer aux prochaines
compétitions européennes ayant opté
cette fois ci pour les couleurs de l'aja
mais moi et puisque nous sommes dans
l'athlétisme signalons pour être complet
qu'à l'issue de la première journée du
match états unis urss qui se dispute à
leningrad union soviétique à trois
points d'avance 55 points à 52 et vous
pourrez suivre cet après-midi sur votre
écran de la première chaîne de
télévision la deuxième journée de ce
match à partir de 15h30 car 15h30 donc
première chez renault en maintenant aux
affaires politiques me fais numéro un du
jour c'est le discours prononcé hier
soir par le président égyptien nasser ce
discours était très attendu car on se
demandait s'il connaît nasser est
accepté ou repousser le dernier plan de
paix proposé par les états unis pour
tenter de mettre fin à l'état de guerre
au moyen-orient le plan rogers et bien
nasser a déclaré qu'en gros il acceptait
ce plan
pendant les israéliens sont sceptiques
ils ont l'impression que l'accord de
nasser est plutôt une sorte de
manoeuvres telles manoeuvres et bien il
s'agirait pour nasser de m en quelque
sorte les états unis au pied du mur en
leur demandant comme gage de leur
volonté réelle de paix de cesser leurs
livraisons d'armes à israël
et s'il ne faisait pas eh bien nasser
pourrait ainsi justifié les militaires
soviétiques a cru qu'il continue de
recevoir de toute manière nasser est il
le seul maître du jeu et bien ce n'est
pas certain il faut compter aussi bien
sûr avec les organisations
palestiniennes
or ce matin le journal el fatah qui est
le porte parole des dix principales
organisations palestiniennes a publié en
première page un éditorial consacré au
plan rogers avec pour seul titre ce mot
non et ce journal palestinien ne fait
aucune allusion au discours du président
nasser une affaire à suivre
indépendamment de ces subtilités
diplomatiques on a assisté hier encore à
un duel de mortier au dessus du canal de
suez regarder ces deux photos
je vous voyais un soldat israélien en
train de charger le canon de son mortier
locaux va partir et bien à droite le
coup est parti il est même tombé dans un
grand nuage de poussière de l'autre côté
du canal sur un fortin occupés par des
égyptiens
en france l'actualité politique et
sociale tourne vraiment au ralenti
simplement à la fin de ce journal michel
tardieu au cours de sa aurique de la
bourse vous parlera des problèmes de
l'industrie automobile en france
il reste évidemment les vacances mais
pour une fois nous n'allons pas vous
montrer ce qui se baignent sur les
plages ou bien ceux qui arpentent les
montagnes nous allons vous parler de
ceux qui ne partent pas en vacances et
ils sont assez nombreux ils sont même
très nombreux puisqu'on estime d'après
les dernières études de l'institut
national de la statistique
environ un français sur deux ne prend
pas de vacances qu'une enquête de louis
doucet
plus de la moitié des français ne
partent pas en vacances
parmi ceux là les agriculteurs ce bien
connu vient en tête 81 18 % restent à la
maison
un enfant sur 2 aussi
un enfant sur deux et 58,4 pour cent des
ouvriers comme madame romano dans de
nouveaux logements a bouleversé la vie
nous ennuie pas partis en vacances
c'est gentil j'ai tapé pour ça ne paie
pas oui j'ai souffert pendant sept ans
alors vous préférez voir les enfants six
enfants à loyer de trept le mari de
madame romano a des problèmes car il
vous prenait pas de vacances pourquoi
j'ai pas les moyens
rien on retrouve ici pour gagner notre
vie vos épaules comment dirais je il
faut travailler il faut gagner il faut
je pouvais viser ago we donc ça je fais
du crédit comme tout le monde vous
pouvez pas envoyer les enfants en
colonie non oui pourquoi je peux pas
j'ai pas les moyens
c'est pas chez elle et que l'onu
confiance pour les enfants pourtant est
maintenant en ce moment là je suis là
dit je suis je ne peux pas oui je ne
peux pas servir
c'est comme les je suis aux commandes et
des joueurs comme un gosse on savait
qu'il y aurait une vitrine qui voit des
bateaux par gourmandise même s'il peut
pas manger
enfin le dota sentence dépasse un petit
peu pour les chiens camion oui c'est un
tableau messieurs un camion couché des
vacances pour les fêtes locales comme ça
les gens qui passent les cas la balle
qui sont devant ça fait plaisir à les
voir les difficultés financières des
familles sont réels je crois que ce
n'était pas la difficulté majeure le
point sur votre vie
non il y a également le le
conditionnement le mythe des vacances
bien entretenues par une publicité par
un parent snobisme actuelle les vacances
égalent déplacements lointains égale
exotisme nous avons constaté que
certaines familles se sentait un peu
gêné d envoyer une carte postale d'un
endroit qui n'était pas un lieu dit
célèbre
et qu'elle préférait quelquefois partir
dans des conditions tout à fait
difficile tout à fait précaire mais loin
plutôt que d séjourner dans un centre
dans une région très touristique très
joli mais peu éloigné de paris
il est regrettable qu'on ne sache pas
que 50 km de paris il y à un centre il y
avait plutôt un centre il ya des
possibilités de vacances bon marché
agréable comme étant des ces gens
merveilleux ça c'est sûr mais ne
demandez pas ce que je peux faire pour
faire venir les gens alors monsieur
nabeul et c'est ici que vous prendrez
vos vacances vous croyez le foot mondial
un toujours pris vos vacances ici ol et
plus de dizaines d'hommes et oui oui
avant je sortais un peu maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous fassiez jetant
rihanna qui brille c'est à juste en face
l'a alors vous aviez 200 mètres à faire
pour venir dans votre jardin ils
passaient vous mettra fin à la peine
vous n'avez jamais eu envie d'aller
ailleurs
belle tant que j'étais bien réussi je ne
suis pas j'ai dû gérer cgt bien vous ne
vouliez pas vous ne pouviez pas c'est
comme toujours en tout ce que vous
voulez alors voyez misés par monsieur
nabli 63 % des inactifs
autrement dit des vieux ne partent pas
en vacances sans l'aide de leur caisse
de retraite certains même comme ces
ouvriers du bâtiment ne seraient jamais
sortis de chez eux
idéal c'est la première fois que vous
preniez des brevets mais je vais la
première aussi madame marie messier de
20 à 15 et là je vous avez 60
qu'est-ce que vous fassiez dans la ville
masson ouais négative pas payé oui et
bien après la guerre de toute votre vie
vous n'avez jamais pu prendre des
vacances en au 24e rang 1 dimanche ça
vous surprend pas un peu ça je pensais
pas qu'on ne peut pas se rendre on n'a
jamais vu ça le pouvoir aux régions
nous allons parler hier de deux
alpinistes italiens qui avaient disparu
près du sommet du mont blanc à 4500
mètres d'altitude et bien ils sont morts
tous les deux une cordée d'alpinistes
espagnol a retrouvé leurs corps qui ont
été descendus dans la vallée par
hélicoptère s'était deux étudiants âgés
de 19 et 21 ans et puis un autre
accident que nous venons d'apprendre par
une dépêche de rabat deux élèves de
l'école de l'air de salon de provence
ont été tuées et 11 blessées dont trois
grièvement dans un accident de la route
ce matin près de fès au maroc donc non
pas d'autres détails pour l'instant sur
cet accident
le procès des meurtriers de l'actrice
américaine sharon tate et de quatre de
ses amis s'ouvre aujourd'hui à los
angeles dans le box des accusés un
hippie des voiliers de 35 ans charles
manson et trois des membres de sa secte
oui il n'aura pas fallu moins de 40
jours au magistrat de los angeles pour
enfin réussir à réunir un jury pour un
procès qui a déjà été plusieurs fois
ajournée vous avez
l'accusé numéro 1 charles manson filmé
en mars dernier après sa première
audition par le juge monson 35 ans déjà
aux prises justice avait fondé une
communauté de hippies mystique et
signifiante à la magie patricia carwin
qu'elle se sent apte keynes et leslie
van houten
ses trois complices qui sont allé voir
le juge en chantant de ces quatre amies
cette tribu c'est ainsi qu'il se désigne
même est accusé également du meurtre
d'un couple
comment cela s'est-il passé devant le
juge demande les journalistes le juge
jim henson il s'est rendu complètement
ridicule comme d'habitude
et puis il a suggéré que j'étais atteint
de folie et moi j'ai suggéré que c'était
lui le fou question êtes-vous réponse
tout est relatif
telle était manson il ya quatre mois
changera-t-il d'attitude
aujourd'hui le procès des meurtriers de
sharon tate sera long très long
il pourrait paraît-il durer six mois en
france une autre affaire judiciaire
particulièrement tragique celle que l'on
appelle le triple crime damien a connu
vient de connaître un épisode
particulièrement insolite pierre
taverniers meurtrier présumé d'un
hôtelier monsieur sauvaud de sa femme et
de leur fille ont refusé obstinément
depuis deux mois de comparaître devant
le juge d'instruction
le magistrat c'est un jeune juge âgé de
27 ans il s'appelle pipolo le magistrat
finalement des sports de combat décidé
de le faire sortir de sa cellule
manu militari il l'a fait à mener dans
son bureau soigneusement ligoté les
pieds et les mains attachées par des
cordes mais quand on a détaché tavernier
dans le bureau du juge
eh bien ça s'est très mal passé écoutez
le témoignage de quelqu'un qui assistait
à la scène c'était le greffier une femme
madame scellier
demandez qu'on enlève le mineur comme
c'est l'habitude de le faire que son âme
au cabinet du juge et avant qu'on ait eu
le temps de préparer son geste il est
saisi la chaise et la lancée de toute
force sur le juge d'instruction qui n'a
eu le temps que de pareilles
avec le bras si bien que la blessure est
au bras mais ça aurait pu tracer la
chaise avait dans la tête
et alors le juge était pliée vraiment
envoyer qui souffrait puis après il a
voulu continuer l'instruction alors à ce
moment-là j'ai procurait était justement
arrivé j'ai dit faut absolument faire
soigner vous pouvez pas rester comme ça
le sang coulait mon amant et on appelait
le tout de suite ambulance des pompiers
c'est ce que pierre taverniers avait
l'habitude d'être violent tout au moins
dans ses propos il avait eu des écrits
vous mettez les magistrats de
saltimbanques en fin 2006 enfin n'avez
pas eu non il n'avait jamais eu de geste
aurait pas préfère quand même chose et
aussi violent il ne devait pas se payer
un avocat
c'est à dire ce n'est votre ci s'est
présenté mais juste venait d'arriver
puisque en fait et tout est fait au
début de l'instruction l'avocat est pas
toujours toujours à l'heure pile et
quand la vraie est arrivé vers cet été
le juge d'instruction en tout cas est
toujours en clinique il a une fracture
ouverte d'un bras et des plaies à la
tête et savannah date vous avez
aujourd'hui un invité ce qui va me
parler d'un livre qui sur un sujet qui
nous est assez cher puisqu'il s'intitule
la caméra notre type travail ça un titre
qui nous touche voici de l'image de de
cette caméra prise par une autre caméra
comme orthez est un un premier roman et
votre héros ou un onglet ressemble à
tous les héros caribana il a deux yeux
avec cette différence qu'il il ajoute un
troisième oeil l'oeil de cette caméra et
qu'après il s'efface complètement
derrière ce troisième oeil est en fait
il n'est plus que l'oeil de sa caméra et
qu'il voit toute la vie ou travaux de
cette caméra
oui en fait c'était l'histoire c'est une
histoire d'amour c'est un homme qui est
passionné par la caméra par le cinéma
par la création de l'image
c est également histoires de
de l'amour de ce héros pour son père
puisque un certain moment chasse en
quelque sorte des les sujets de plus en
plus vrai et il va filmer la mort de son
père y filme à l'agonie de son père
atteint de l'infarctus et j'arrête car
j'ai vu il ya peut-être non un an et
demi fait divers dans la presse au japon
on a projeté un film d'un réalisateur
qui devait s'appeler ih oulahri qarawat
un petit peu comme le prix nobel qui
aime filmer l'agonie de son père atteint
de cancer cette agonie s'était prolongée
durant durant trois mois vous êtes
partie de ce fait différé pas vu le film
j'avais vu l'information dans un journal
a effectivement je fais partie de ce
fait divers
alors le sujet pourrait paraître
dramatique mais il faut dire que c'est
un livre bien sûr grinçant mais avec un
certain humour et un peu une pointe de
philosophie c'est l'union les restes
d'un narratrice qui est la propre femme
de wang est mon héros est la narratrice
raconte avec son stylo un petit peu ce
qu'elle doit faire à son mari avec
certains ici au deuxième degré et celle
encore une histoire d'amour puisque
finalement la livre l'histoire de ce
couple est ce qu'on vous qui êtes
réalisateur albert terme et réalisateur
de radio radio nul je suis dans la
maison de kennedy est ce que vous voyez
la vie à travers ma micro ou à travers
une caméra
moi ce que vous avez envie dans la vie à
travers une caméra je dirais que je vois
davantage que je davantage envie de voir
la vie au bout de mon stylo enfin du
moins des mois au point de vue création
et je crois que même
comment y âge l'image pure où l'immense
honneur sauf finalement quand même d'un
stylo c'est à dire exactement le
contraire que soutient mais maintenant
je me retourne vers ricqlès car j'ai
appris que le prochain roman de plus de
monter commencé ici dans un studio de
télévision avec la première image d'un
présentateur ans dans un studio de
télévision avec une présence forte et la
télévision
alors on fait attention mais on a joué
dans une présentatrice c'est que c'est
moi c'est sa finale eq sentirez pas de
la partie magazine journal
ils ont commencé par l'actualité
philatélique
c'est aujourd'hui la philatélie à
l'heure du festival d'avignon une
émission de jacques nicolet 24e festival
d'avignon est présentée du 15 au 26
juillet pour la seconde fois cette année
cette expérience fut inauguré en effet
l'année dernière du théâtre pour les
enfants au répertoire de ces
représentations spécialisé s'inscrivent
des oeuvres où le jeune auditoire peut
voir évoluer sur scène les héros des
contes de perrault ou des frères grimm
à moins que ce ne soit ceux du folklore
national ou étranger
les timbres vous le pensez bien ne
manquent pas d'illustrer les belles
histoires qui ont fait rêver et ont
enchanté des générations de jeunes des
cinq continents
mais ce qui peut être et merveilles
davantage les enfants que le jeu humain
c'est la représentation donnée par ces
petits personnages extraordinaires que
sont les marionnettes dont les facéties
et les aventures donne plus encore libre
cours à l'imagination des jeunes
spectateurs usage des marionnettes
remonte à la plus haute antiquité
le japon pays de tradition perpétuée par
exemple le théâtre debout drac ou
l'italie le classicisme de ce genre de
spectacle immortalisée par polichinelle
et pinocchio la france adopté le théâtre
de marionnettes dès la fin du xvième
siècle et à partir de cette époque il y
a eu des théâtre ambulant de
marionnettes dans tous les pays d'europe
les poupées again ou s ils se montrés au
xviiie siècle dans les foires puis dans
les théâtres de fantoches le 19e siècle
lui
vie l'apparition de guignol création
lyonnaise qui n'a pas la chance d'avoir
encore son timbre notre siècle marque
une renaissance de cet art qui perpétue
une très ancienne tradition et qui
continue de faire la joie en direct ou
par le truchement de la télévision d'un
jeune public toujours avide d'aventurés
et de féerie au moment où les pouvoirs
publics nationaux et internationaux met
l'accent sur la nécessité de sauvegarder
nos forêts qui sont vraiment un des
facteurs de notre survie futur et après
les désastres que l'on sait la ville de
nice vient d'émettre une flamme non
incendiaires une flamme postale qui au
contraire rappelle à chacun de nous sait
devoir civique envers la nature
sept autres flamme elle nous incite à
voyager par chemin de fer de même que
celle ci qui nous suggèrent même
d'emprunter les trains autos à propos de
train pour la première fois au monde une
exposition philatélique itinérante
circulent sur voie ferrée aux etats unis
un trait composé de neuf wagons est
tirée par la célèbre locomotive flying
scotsman lilly a été affecté et elle
cette exposition vient d'entre eux
pointent à travers le continent
américain une randonnée qui la conduira
de ce la tonne au texas à green bay dans
le wisconsin
c'est bien nous allons maintenant passer
à la mode aujourd'hui la collection de
carven et jacques brie jacques griffe
pardon je vous rappel c'est un reportage
dit cela ni ligne féminine évocation de
la belle époque chez mademoiselle carven
qui vous parle de sa collection
vous voyez ce premier modèle c'est ma
robe de mariée et c'est une amazone très
sûre d'elle ils se marient à la campagne
la campagne oui peut-être à cheval même
et toute la collection est extrêmement
féminine dans des beaucoup de valeur à
la femme et vos robes d'après midi eh
bien ils sont très sûrs avec des tissus
très moelleuse on sent le corps de
nouveau les manteaux sont très
confortables et aura des bottes pas très
long mais d'une longueur bien équilibré
le soir tout est très longes quoi le
soir le loup et puis également à la
cheville une deuxième une deuxième
langue heures pour les plus jeunes c'est
à ces adorables et les robes du soir
sont très molle aussi très féminine
et souvent brodé oui souvent prôné à la
taille pour marquer
de nouveau la taille fine à 37 cm du sol
la longueur pour le jour chez jacques
griffe tout est à 30 cm du sol pour le
jour les tailleurs les manteaux que vous
voyez celui ci voyez vous qui êtes un
manteau du sport kerver cible également
j'ai beaucoup de modèles qui ne sont pas
doublés c'est ça ce sont des tissus qui
sont réversibles et gemmayzé mener car
c'est c'est plus léger en même temps
c'est c'est beaucoup plus léger voici
également une redingote pour l'après
midi qui est toujours à prendre sept
centimètres du sol il vous donnait sur
le côté qui est aussi sans doublure avec
des surpiqûres les discussions
suffisamment épais et nous avons avec un
système de d'ateliers n'est ce pas que
nous avons pu faire les au relais et les
rendre tout de même extrêmement nettes
les longues heures du soir les longues
heures du soir sont également à 37 à
part quelques robes qui arrive à la
cheville n'est ce pas par exemple cette
horde de velours est à 37
c'est un velours de couleur améthyste
avec une incrustation français sur les
côtés voyez vous et puis alors j'ai des
robes de là mais j'ai des robes de
brochets des mousselines également la
main et beaucoup de velours
nous allons passer maintenant à la
bourse de paris avoue michel tardieu
bien si la mode est déjà à l'hiver la
bourse elle est toujours en été et
commence aujourd'hui son mois d'août et
elle ne commence fort bien le marché et
ferme je pense qu'il ya déjà pas mal de
séances qu'on n'a pas pas mal de
semaines qu'on n'a pas vu une pareille
séance l'ensemble des valeurs monde
hier on était légèrement sélectif
aujourd'hui la hausse est générale
c'est d'ailleurs assez amusant de voir
que cette hausse du mois d'août qu'on
annonce depuis des semaines est exact au
rendez vous c'est un phénomène boursiers
assez rare d'un seul coup les opérateurs
n'ont semble ne plus se préoccuper de la
situation à la rentrée
alors qu'il ya quelques semaines au
contraire il était assez préoccupé le
pineau boursières comme l'opinion tout
court est versatile
il faut dire qu'elle a le temps de se
retourner puis
or fois avant la rentrée les deux
excitateur qui la sq ont bougé dans un
sens ou dans l'autre sont d'une part la
conjoncture monétaire international et à
ce propos on circule beaucoup de bruit
aujourd'hui en bourse on se préoccupe du
marché des changes de genève et comme
mourad houas quel que soit le mois des
décisions monétaires les bourses si on a
tendance à croire qu'à moi d'où ne veut
pas se passer sans que les décisions
monétaires soient reprises l'autre
excitateur bien sûr c'est la conjoncture
intérieure en france est l'alternative
la plus simple est de savoir si les
tendances inflationnistes persisteront
ou si au contraire les tendance au
ralentissement qui sont constatés
actuellement tendance déjà perceptible
et bien s'étendre
le ralentissement de la consommation
intérieure apparaît pour l'instant dans
les dernières statistiques du conseil
national du crédit
les spas les français paraissent
consacrer une part croissante de leurs
revenus
à l'époque nos pas et là ça dépanne
qu'ils investissent à long terme mais à
les pannes qu'ils gardent sous forme
liquide ou en dépôt dans les manches ce
ralentissement des dépenses des français
est particulièrement sensible dans le
secteur de l'automobile
pendant le mois de juin les
immatriculations de voitures neuves ont
baissé de 12 9% par rapport à juin 1969
et l'ensemble du premier semestre de
cette année accuse un recul des
immatriculations de 18 8% sur le 1er
semestre
1969 alors bien sûr les producteurs
dénoncent les restrictions de crédit à
la consommation décidé il y a dix mois
et la chambre syndicale des
constructeurs d'automobiles et mais la
crainte que la décision prise par les
mêmes autorités monétaires au mois de
juin de ramener de 40 à 30% le versement
initial pour l'achat d'une voiture neuve
et bien que cette mesure ne soit pas
suffisante pour relancer le marché de
façon sensible la diminution des ventes
d'automobiles sur le marché intérieur ne
signifie pas que les constructeurs ont
produit moins depuis le début de l'année
au contraire leur production s'est
accrue
elle a augmenté de 12 8% pour les
voitures de tourisme et de 1,6 pour cent
ce n'est pas beaucoup pour les véhicules
utilitaires
bien sûr la différence c'est
l'exportation qu'il a absorbé
l'exportation a pris le relais de la
demande intérieure
en juin les exportations de voitures
françaises ont été plus fortes de 46,1 %
quand
1969 aujourd'hui six voitures françaises
sur dix qui sont des usines sont vendus
à l'étranger c'est le taux d'exportation
le plus fort de toute industrie
automobile mondial bien sûr les bons
résultats emporter ainsi à l'extérieur
sont intéressants et les constructeurs
en sont satisfaits mais ils se plaignent
quand même parce que il est toujours
dangereux à leur avis que les
entreprises dépendent dans une
proportion trop importante des marchés
extérieurs et de la conjoncture des
autres pays et d'autre part le
constructeur souligne que bien souvent
ils gagnent plus d'argent sur le marché
intérieur où la concurrence est moins
rude pour eux rien n'est jamais parfait
les constructeurs d'automobiles se
plaignent de trop vendre à l'étranger
alors que les pouvoirs publics eux se
plaignent que la plupart des industries
françaises ne vendent pas assez de
produits finis à l'étranger la direction
des relations extérieures du ministère
des finances a fait remarquer récemment
que les exportations françaises de
produits finis c'est à dire les produits
qui englobe le plus de valeur ajoutée
ceux qui sont plus intéressants pour
l'industrie du pays et bien que ces
exportations de produits finis ne
représente que 44 % des exportations
françaises alors qu'ils représentent 63
% des exportations allemandes ou
italiennes plus un pays est
industrialisé plus normalement ils
exploitent de produits finis donc les
structures du commerce extérieur de la
france ne sont pas encore tout à fait
celle d'un grand pays industriel et
surtout sur mon âge automobile qui comme
nous venons de le voir et le plus beau
fleuron du commerce extérieur français
aujourd'hui en bourse la hausse générale
des valeurs s'accompagne d'une ourse des
mines d'or et de l'or et certains
observateurs se disent que ce retour de
faveur ce retour en faveur du métal qui
coïncide avec la aux autres valeurs et
peut-être tout simplement le résultat
des nouvelles craintes inflationnistes
chez les financiers c'est un petit peu
curieux de parler de crâne a pas
sioniste au moment où précisément la
consommation tend à ralentir mais
l'exemple américain
montrer que la coexistence de ces deux
facteurs n'était pas toujours impossible
et ré boursière toujours tendance à
croire un petit peu que ce qui est vrai
des états unis il est toujours de la
france
en fait cela ne semble pas tout à fait
évident heureusement ici la bourse de
paris à vous j'affine alexandre et la
meinau et messieurs télé midi est
maintenant terminée je vous souhaite à
tous une très agréable journée à demain